it's the start of the night shift but
paramedics on day shift are still
waiting outside hospitals as the
Handover takes place at ambulance
headquarters so there's going to be for
a cruise now end of changeover to try
and get away uh home one time and get
relieved at the Ed
within minutes they're queuing up
outside belfast's Royal Victoria
Hospital the emergency department Under
Pressure Laura didn't expect to be doing
this when she joined the service two
years ago we spend a lot of our time
frustratingly waiting at Edie and when
you hear calls on the channel for cat
one calls that need coverage and the
need Crews and we've maybe Saturday
these for
10 hours 11 hours for some of our shifts
John's been a paramedic for 19 years he
used to treat 10 patients in a 12 hour
shift last Monday he treated just two in
a shift that lasted 15 hours the first
person we huddle on the stretcher for
over six hours when they said a hospital
and the second patient we had for four
hours before getting relieved by another
crew so we could actually get them up
until I would say to start a covered
I never had to look after Pierce in an
ambulance I would take the person
straight into
the hospital last month the ambulance
service lost a record 13 000 hours 34 of
its operational capacity while patients
waited outside hospitals
we're interviewing the chief executive
when a 999 call illustrates The Dilemma
a vehicle fire potentially with someone
trapped inside keep yourself as safe as
you can as safe as you can alright
okay just keep yourself safe can you see
anybody can you hear anybody screaming
even just while we're talking I hear one
of your team responding to a road
traffic accident when capacity inhibits
your ability to respond to other
incidents does it increase the risk to
life
it absolutely increases the risk to to
life and to to Serious harm you know if
there's 13 and a half thousand dollars
that we are unable to respond to other
calls waiting while we're waiting with
patients outside in Ed there are many
people during that time who are very ill
who need who need an ambulance in recent
days two Northern Ireland hospitals said
they were operating Beyond capacity and
a third declared a major incident due to
lack of space
last week a 77 year old woman died while
waiting on a trolley at this hospital
and yet there's no one to take the lead
on addressing this crisis because
Northern Ireland currently has no
functioning government and no Health
minister
and those on the front line bear the
brunt of that political failure
paramedics battling night and day to
save lives David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast